Socrates was one of the most important
figures in Western philosophy celebrated
for his contributions to ethics theory
of knowledge and diale reasoning born in
Athens Greece in the year 469 B.C to a
stonemason so fiscus and a midwife fit
Socrates likely received a basic
education little is known about his
childhood but he served as a soldier in
the Peloponnesian War Socrates is best
known for his method of questioning now
called the Socratic method a form of
dialc inquiry aimed at uncovering
assumptions and encouraging critical
thinking unlike many philosophers of
this time Socrates wrote nothing down
with his ideas instead being known
through the works of his students
especially Plato his philosophy revolved
around the pursuit of wisdom in the
belief that virtue is Central to a
meaningful life he famously declared the
unexamined life is not worth living
Socrates challenged the moral
complacency and intellectual arrogance
of his peers advocating for self-
knowledge and ethical introspection his
questioning often exposed contradictions
in people's beliefs earning him both
admirers and critics he rejected wealth
and materialism living modestly and
engaging with Athenians in public spaces
in 399 b.c. Socrates was tried and
executed for allegedly corrupting the
youth and being ungodly defended himself
eloquently refusing to abandon his
principles even if it meant saving his
life he accepted his death by drinking
poison this resulted in him becoming a
martyr for free thoughts Socrates
profoundly influenced Western philosophy
shaping the work of Plato Aristotle and
countless others his emphasis on reason
dialogue and ethic IAL inquiry remains
Central to philosophy and education
Plato was a Monumental figure in Western
philosophy a student of Socrates and
teacher of Aristotle born into a wealthy
and influential Athenian family either
in the year 428 or 427 BC his early life
was marked by privilege and in education
in music poetry and gymnastics the
political turmoil of Athens during his
youth combined with the execution of his
mentor Socrates deeply influenced
Plato's philosophical Outlook Plato
founded the academy in Athens one of the
first institutions of higher learning in
the western world where he taught and
wrote extensively his Works written as
dialogues feature Socrates as a central
figure and explore topics such as ethics
politics metaphysics epistemology and
education the Republic one of his most
famous works presents his vision of a
just Society ruled by philosopher Kings
and outlines his theory of forms which
claims that the material world is a
shadow of a higher unchanging reality
Plato's philosophy emphasized reason the
pursuit of truth and the importance of a
virtuous life his allegory of the cave
illustrates the transformative power of
education and philosophy advocating for
the Enlighten to guide Society he also
contributed significantly to discussions
on the nature of knowledge proposing
that true understanding comes from
contemplating the Eternal and perfect
forms rather than relying on sensory
experience Plato's ideas laid the
foundation for much of Christian
theology political Theory and philosophy
his Academy remained a hub of
intellectual activity for centuries
shaping thinkers like Aristotle Plato
died around 347 BCE and his works are
are some of the most influential in
history inspiring debates on ethics
politics and the nature of reality for
over 2,000 years Aristotle was a Greek
philosopher whose work shaped Western
thought across numerous disciplines
including science ethics politics and
metaphysics born in Saga a small town in
northern Greece in the year 384 b.c. he
was the son of nicus a physician to the
Macedonian Royal courts this early
exposure to medicine and biology may
have sparked his lifelong interest in
the natural world orphan as a child
Aristotle was raised by a guardian in
Sensi Athens at age 17 to study at
Plato's Academy where he remained for 20
years although deeply influenced by
Plato Aristotle diverged from his
teachers ideas emphasizing empirical
observation and rejecting Plato's theory
of forms after Plato's death Aristotle
spent time traveling and conducting
biological research before being invited
to tutor Alexander the Great in
Macedonia this role gave him access to
resources and experiences that informed
his later works around 335 BCE Aristotle
returned to Athens and established the
lysium a school where he taught and
conducted research in diverse Fields
including logic ethics politics rhetoric
biology and physics his methodical
approach and insistent on systematic
observation laid the groundwork for
modern science keyw Works include
nicomaki and ethics which explores the
concept of virtue in the good life in
politics a written work on governance in
the organization of society Aristotle's
philosophy emphasized the importance of
reason moderation and practical wisdom
he also came up with the idea of the
golden mean advocating for a balanced
virtuous life he would also later
propose a comprehensive cosmology and
theories of causation that influenced
medieval and Renaissance thought
Aristotle died in 322 B.C in yubia and
his contributions to philosophy science
and logic have had a profound impact
establishing him as one of History's
Greatest intellectual figures earning
him the title the philosopher in the
Middle Ages confucious was born as Kong
in the state of Lou which is modern-day
Shandong China in the year 551 B.C and
he was a Chinese philosopher whose
teaching shaped the moral and social
fabric of East Asia raised in modest
circumstances his father a military
officer died when confucious was young
leaving the family in poverty despite
these challenges confucious developed a
deep love of learning studying history
music and traditional religious acts
confucious worked as a teacher
attracting disciples who sought his
guidance on ethics governance and proper
conduct his philosophy centered on the
cultivation of virtue moral integrity
and the importance of harmonious social
relationships he emphasized five core
virtues benevolence righteousness
propriety wisdom and faithfulness these
principles form the basics of
Confucianism a system of thought that
deeply influenced Chinese society and
governance confucious believed in the
power of Education to transform
individuals and advocated for rulers to
lead by example practicing moral virtue
rather than relying on coercion he
idealized a hierarchial but benevolent
social order with filial peity which
means respect for parents and ancestors
as a Cornerstone his teachings were
compiled after his death which occurred
in the year 479 B.C by his followers and
the analex confucious spent most of his
life traveling between states offering
his Council to rulers but his political
Ambitions were largely unfulfilled
despite this his ideas gained prominence
after his death especially during the
Han Dynasty when Confucianism became the
state philosophy confucious is known as
one of the most influenced figures in
world history and his ideas continue to
shape ethical thought education and
governance in East Asia and Beyond
promoting values of respect Duty and
Harmony that resonate across multiple
cultures in through thousands of years
Augustine of Hippo was an early
Christian philosopher whose ideas
significantly shaped Western
Christianity and philosophy born on
November 13th 354 enaste which is now
modern day Algeria Augustine grew up in
a romanized North African family and his
father Patricia was a pagan
while his mother Monica was a devout
Christian who greatly influenced
Augustine's later spiritual journey as a
youth Augustine was highly intelligent
but rebellious indulging in pleasures
and questioning religious doctrines he
studied rhetoric and philosophy in
Carthage where he encountered sister
Ro's writings and became captivated by
The Pursuit Of Truth dissatisfied with
Christianity he turned to manism a
dualistic religious sect and later to
neoplatonism which profoundly influenced
his thoughts Augustine's life took a a
transformative turn when he moved to
Milan in 384 influenced by the sermons
of Ambrose the bishop of Milan and his
mother's persistent prayers Augustine
converted to Christianity in 386 he was
baptized by Ambrose in 387 and returned
to Africa where he founded a community
of monks before becoming the bishop of
hippo in 395 Augustine's Major Works
include confessions an introspective
spiritual autobiography in the city of
God a defense of Christianity against
Roman critics his philosophical
contributions focused on the nature of
God free will and the problem of evil he
argued that humans are inherently sinful
due to the original sin and emphasize
divine grace as essential for salvation
Augustine's combination of Christian
doctrine with classical philosophy
specifically neoplatonism shaped
medieval thought and laid the groundwork
for Western theology his ideas on faith
predestination and the relationship
between church and state have influenced
countless philosophers Augustine died on
August 26th 4:30 during the siege of
Hippo by the vand his legacy endures as
one of Christianity's most profound and
influential thinkers Thomas aquinus was
a Dominican Monk and theologian whose
combination of faith and reason
profoundly influenced Western philosophy
and Catholic theology born in rasa Italy
in the year 1225 to a noble family
aquinus was the youngest of nine
children his family expected him to
pursue a career in the church but they
initially opposed his decision to join
the Dominican order which valued poverty
in wandering preaching despite desite
family resistance including imprisonment
by his brothers aquinus remained
committed to his calling he studied in
Naples Paris and cologne under renowned
Scholars like albertus Magnus he became
deeply influenced by Aristotelian
philosophy which he sought to reconcile
with Christian theology his intellect
earned him the nickname Angelic doctor
and one of his most significant works is
the Suma theologica a combination of
Christian doctrine and Aristotelian
philosophy in this text he addressed
topics like the existence of God the
nature of Morality In the relationship
between faith and reason aquinus is best
known for his five ways a logical
argument for the existence of God
including the cosmological and
Theological arguments aquinus believed
that faith and reason are harmonious
with reason serving as a tool to
understand Divine truth his ethical
philosophy emphasized natural law
proposing that moral principles are
rooted in human nature and discernible
through reason aquinas' ideas shaped
Catholic Doctrine influencing the
development of Scholastic ISM and
serving as the foundation of modern
Catholic Education in the year 1323 he
was officially declared a doctor of the
church Thomas aquinas's integration of
philosophy and theology left a large
impact on both religious and secular
thoughts his Works continue to remain
important in discussions on metaphysics
ethics and the interplay between science
and religion uring his place as one of
History's Greatest thinkers Renee de
karts was a French philosopher
mathematician and scientist often called
the father of modern philosophy born in
lah in terrain which is now decart
France in 1596 he was the youngest of
three children in a moderately wealthy
family his mother died when he was young
and he was raised primarily by his
grandmother deart was educated at the
Jesuit college of La flesh where he
excelled in mathematics and classical
studies later earning a law degree from
the University of pias deart traveled
extensively throughout Europe serving in
the military and engaging with
scientific and philosophical communities
his groundbreaking philosophical ideas
are laid out in works like discourse on
the method and meditations on first
philosophy in these texts deart saw a
foundation for knowledge that could
withstand doubt his famous assertion
kago ergosum which translates to I think
therefore I am established
self-awareness as the first certainty
deart emphasized rationalism arguing
that reason and Mathematics provide the
basics for understanding the natural
world he developed cartisian dualism
suggesting there is a distinction
between mind and body this idea had
profound implications for philosophy
psychology and Science in in mathematics
deart introduced the cartisian
coordinate system merging algebra and
geometry which became foundational for
modern calculus and analytical geometry
his work in Optics physics and Anatomy
also Advanced scientific understanding
in 1649 deart moved to Sweden to tutor
Queen Christina but the harsh climate
affected his health resulting in his
death from pneumonia in 1650 de cart
influence over philosophy Science and
Mathematics including his method of
Doubt emphasis on reason and dualistic
framework reshaped intellectual thought
laying the groundwork for the
enlightenment in modern scientific
inquiry his legacy endures as a central
figure in Western philosophy John Lock
was an English philosopher whose ideas
on empiricism government and individual
rights profoundly influence modern
thought and political systems born in
rington Somerset in 1632 lock was raised
in a Puritan household his father a
lawyer and Soldier and ured he received
a good education and he attended
Westminster School in later Christ
Church in Oxford where he studied
philosophy medicine in the Natural
Sciences Lock's interest in medicine led
him to work with prominent scientists
including Robert Bole and Thomas cenam
and he became a fellow the Royal Society
his political career began when he
became secretary to Anthony Ashley
Cooper the Earl of chasbury a
relationship that deeply influenced his
political philosophy Lock's most
significant Works include an essay
concerning human understanding where he
argued that the mind is a blank state of
birth and knowledge is derived from
experience through sensory perception
and reflection this idea laid the
foundation for empiricism and challenge
Notions of innate ideas in his two
treatises of government lock Advanced
the concept of natural rights such as
life liberty and property arguing that
governments must derive their power from
the consent of the governed these ideas
were revolutionary opposing absolute
monarchy and justifying resistance to
tyrannical rule Lock's philosophy
profoundly influenced the enlightenment
shaping modern liberalism
constitutionalism and theories of
Education as expressed in some thoughts
concerning education his political
theories inspired the American and
French revolutions directly influencing
documents like the US declaration of
independence John Lock died in 1704 in
England leaving a legacy as one of
history's most influential thinkers
David Hume was a Scottish philosopher
historian Economist and essayist
renowned for his influential Works in
philosophy and contributions to the
enlightenment born on May 7th 1711 in
Edinburg Scotland Hume grew up in a
modest but educated family his father
died when Hume was young leaving his
widowed mother to raise him and his
siblings as a child he was very gifted
entering the University of Edinburg at
age 12 where he initially studied law a
gravitated toward philosophy and
literature Hume is best known for his
empiricism and skepticism which
profoundly challenged traditional
philosophical ideas his Major Works
include A Treatise of human nature where
he argued that human knowledge derives
entirely from s experience rejecting
inate ideas he introduced the problem of
induction questioning the logical
justification of assuming that future
events will mirror past experiences
hum's views on causation morality and
religion were groundbreaking yet
controversial with his criticism of
traditional Arguments for God's
existence earning him a reputation as an
atheist in addition to philosophy Hume
authored the history of England a multiv
valume work known for its narrative
style and historical analysis he also
engaged in political economy influencing
thinkers like Adam Smith hume's
philosophy laid the foundation for later
thinkers such as Emanuel Kant he
influenced disciplines ranging from
psychology to political Theory
emphasizing empirical evidence and
critical thinking despite being largely
unappreciated in his time he was
celebrated in his later years living a
comfortable life in Edinburg he died on
August 25th 1776 leaving a legacy that
continues to shape modern philosophy
John jacqu Russo was a Swiss born
philosopher writer and composer whose
ideas influenced the enlightenment the
French Revolution in modern political
and educational thoughts born on June
28th 1712 in Geneva Russo's mother died
shortly after his birth and his father
fled Geneva when Russo was 10 leaving
him in the care of relatives as a Young
Man Russo wandered Europe supporting
himself through various jobs including
tutoring and music copying Russo's major
philosophical Works include discourse on
the origin and basis of inequality among
men the social contract and ail or on
education in these writings rouso
explored themes of human nature freedom
and the structure of society and he
argued that humans were naturally good
but corrupted by civilization in the
social contract he introduced the
concept of the general will and the idea
that legitimate political Authority
rises from a social agreement among free
and equal individuals in ail Russo
outlined a philosophy of education
emphasizing natural development in
individual Freedom which greatly
influenced Progressive educational
theories his critique of of
institutional religion in this work led
to a lot of backlash and he was forced
to flee France Russo also contributed to
the Romantic Movement emphasizing
emotion nature and individuality in his
works such as confessions an early
example of modern autobiography Russo's
ideas had a profound impact on the
French Revolution inspiring calls for
equality in Democratic governance his
emphasis on natural rights in the
general will remains Central to
political philosophy despite his
controversial life marked by conflict
with his peers and being exiled Russo
died on July 2nd 1778 in ironville
France but his vision of freedom and
equality continues to resonate in
political educational and philosophical
discourse Emanuel Kant was a German
philosopher who considered one of the
most influential figures in Western
philosophy born on April 22nd 1724 in
kingburg which is now kenrad Russia KH
was raised in a modest household his
parents were devout pietists which
instilled in him a strong work ethic in
moral discipline kant's Early Education
emphasized religion in Latin but his
intellectual curiosity led him to study
philosophy mathematics and science at
the University of kingburg K spent most
of his life in kingburg working as a
private tutor and later as a professor
at the University his critical
philosophy revolutionized the field
beginning with the seminal work critique
of pure reason in it Kant sought to
bridge The Divide between rationalism
and empiricism arguing that while
knowledge begins with experience it is
also shaped by innate structures of the
mind he introduced the concept of the
categorical imperative a Cornerstone of
his moral philosophy which asserts that
actions should be guided by principles
that could be universally applied K's
critique of practical reason and criti
of judgment expanded his ideas to ethics
and his philosophy emphasized human
autonomy rationality and the idea that
individuals are ends in themselves not
means to an end K's work reshaped
metaphysics epistemology ethics and
aesthetic influencing philosophers such
as Hegel Marx and contemporary thinkers
his ideas support modern concepts of
Human Rights moral responsibility and
International Peace despite never
traveling far from kingburg K's
intellectual reach was vast and he was
known for his discipline routine and
modest lifestyle with him passing away
on February 12th 1804 his legacy endures
as a Cornerstone of Western philosophy
shaping debates on reason morality and
human dignity gayor wilham Dr Hegel was
a German philosopher whose ideas
profoundly influenced modern thought
specifically in philosophy history and
political Theory born on August 27th
1770 in stutgart Germany Hegel grew up
in a middleclass Lutheran Family he
excelled academically studying Theology
and philosophy at the tubing or stiff
where he befriended future philosophers
friederick holderlin and friederick
skelling higel began his career as a
private tutor and later taught at
universities eventually securing a
position as a professor at the
University of Berlin in 1818 his
philosophy is most famously outlined in
works such as phenomenology of spirit
science of logic and philosophy of
Rights hegel's philosophy is grounded in
the ideas of dialytic a process of
development through contradictions in
their resolution he propose that history
unfolds through a diale process driven
by the world Spirit seeking
self-realization Central to his thought
is the concept of the spirit or mind in
the idea that reality is a rational
interconnected whole hegel's ideas on
free freom and the state had a major
impact he argued that individual freedom
is realized within the framework of
ethical life encompassing family civil
society and the states hegel's Legacy
extends to Art religion and science
shaping movements such as German
idealism Marxism and existentialism
despite critiques of his abstract ideas
his work remains Central to
understanding modernity and human
developments Hegel died on November 14th
1831 during a kalera outbreak in Berlin
his diale method and vision of History
continued to influence philosophy
politics and cultural Theory to this day
KL Marx was a German philosopher
Economist historian sociologist and
revolutionary whose ideas shaped modern
political thought and inspired movements
worldwide born on May 5th 1818 in trior
Germany Marx grew up in a middle class
Jewish Family that converted to
Lutheranism to avoid anti-semitic
restrictions Marx excelled academically
and studied law history and philosophy
at the universities of of Bon Berlin and
Jenna influenced by hilan philosophy in
the materialism of Ludwick forbach Marx
developed a critical view of society
focusing on class struggle in the
conditions of the working class he
became a journalist writing for radical
newspapers but his revolutionary ideas
forced him into Exile in Paris Brussels
and eventually London Marx's most
significant Works include the Communist
Manifesto co-written with friederick les
in DOS capital in these Works Marx
introduced Concepts like historical
materialism which is the idea that
economic structures shape social and
political life and the critique of
capitalism as being inherently
exploitative he argued that the working
class would overthrow the ruling class
leading to a classless stateless society
based on communal ownership Marx's ideas
laid the foundation for Marxism
influencing socialist and communist
movements globally he also contributed
to the political economy analyzing
capitalism's contradictions including
the tendency for crisis and inequality
despite enduring poverty and personal
hardship 's intellectual Legacy is
profound his critique of capitalism
inspired revolutionary movements such as
the Russian Revolution and continues to
inform discussions on inequality and
labor rights Marx died on March 14th
1883 in London leaving a polarizing
Legacy while his ideas have been debated
and adapted his analysis of power class
and economy remains an important aspect
of modern social and political Theory
Frederick n was a German philosopher
poet and cultural critic whose
provocative ideas challenged the
foundations of of Western thought born
on October 15th 1844 in rockan Prussia
n's father a Lutheran Pastor died when n
was 5 leaving his family in modest
circumstances raised in a household
dominated by women n excelled
academically eventually studying
philology at the University of Leipzig
at just 24 n became a professor of
philology at the University of Basil but
chronic health issues forced him to
resign in 1879 he spent much of his
later life in solitude writing many
Works while traveling across Europe and
some of his key Works include Thus Spoke
zerra Beyond Good and Evil the genealogy
of morals in the will of power which was
released after his death a central
concept to his philosophy is the Uber
MCH which translates to Superman an
individual who transcends conventual
morality to create their own values he
famously declared God is dead critiquing
religion and traditional morality as
constraints on human potential n also
explored themes of nihilism the idea
that life lacks inherent meaning in the
world of power a fundamental driving
force in individuals and societies his
style marked by poetic language made his
philosophy very influential though
largely unrecognized in his lifetime n's
ideas profoundly impacted existentialism
postmodernism and psychology his
critique of morality and power dynamics
inspired thinkers like Jean Paul SRA
Michelle fuk and Carl Jang in 1889 n
suffered a mental breakdown likely due
to syphilis and spent his final years in
incapacitation resulting in his death on
August 25th 1900 controversially
associated with later political
movements n's work continues to provoke
debate and Inspire interpretations
across disciplines lewig wienstein was
an Austrian British philosopher who
profoundly influenced 20th century
philosophy specifically in logic
language and epistemology born on April
26th 1889 in Vienna Austria wienstein
was the youngest of eight children in a
wealthy and cultured family his
upbringing was both privileged and
challenging marked by in familial
expectations and personal struggles with
identity and purpose initially studying
mechanical engineering in Berlin and
Manchester wienstein became fascinated
with the foundations of mathematics
leading him to study philosophy under
berin Russell at Cambridge his early
work culminated in the tracus logico
philosophicus a groundbreaking text that
proposed a picture theory of language
asserting that language's role is to
represent facts about the world
wienstein believed this work solved all
philosophical problems and he left
Academia to live a simple life as a
school teacher in Monastery Gardener
however wienstein returned to Cambridge
in the late 1920s where he radically
revised his views marking the beginning
of his later philosophy in the
philosophical investigations one of his
works that was published after his death
wienstein critiqued his earlier work and
explored the idea of language as a
social activity governed by language
games he argued that the meaning of
words is determined by their use in
specific context challenging rigid
definition of language and Concepts
wienstein ideas reshaped analytical
philosophy influencing areas such as
Linguistics cognitive science and the
philosophy of Mind despite his strict
and mysterious personality as well as
his unconventional teaching methods he
left a profound Legacy wienstein died on
April 29th 1951 in Cambridge England in
his philosophical contributions
emphasizing Clarity the limits of
language and the connection between
thought and reality remain foundational
to Modern philosophical disc course
bridging logic and Human Experience in
innovative ways thank you very much for
watching this video and if you learned
something make sure to leave a like
comment down below which philosophers
are your favorites and subscribe if you
would like to see more videos like this
one thank you again and goodbye